der russische staat der zeigt weiterhin
sein böses gesicht bei ihrer mission die
hafenstadt mario pohl im südosten der
ukraine einzunehmen da geht die
russische armee sogar über kinderleichen
und der russische außenminister der
rettet sich in lügen
in den morgenstunden des 9 märz
attackiert russland ein ukrainisches
kinderkrankenhaus eine rakete vernichtet
alles der schock bei den menschen denn
mario pohl ist groß
der ukrainische präsident wladimir
selensky gab heute die offiziellen
zahlen der opfer bekannt drei tote
darunter ein kind ein kleines mädchen 17
weitere personen sind verletzt der
russische staat will davon nichts wissen
und versuchte die bluttat zu
rechtfertigen
diese entbindungsklinik kraft wir sehen
nicht das erste mal diese
historische berufe das angebot neuer
taten begangen wirbel seitens der
russischen streitkräfte
am siebten märz vor drei tagen
oder sechs uhr mesz ich weiß es nicht
genau aber es bleibt mehr retten
sicherheitsratssitzung
hat unsere redaktion faktische
maßgeblichen bereichen dass diese
bindung spickel so lange von dem
nationalistischen bataillons oft besetzt
wurde es von dort wurden alle
patientinnen alle frauen an der
krankenschwestern alle erste schon
längst evakuiert dieses krankenhaus war
eine einsatz basis des ultra radikalen
per software
doch es kommt noch schlimmer lavrov
spricht noch immer nicht von einem
angriff auf die ukraine als ihre frage
ob wir
andere länder angreifen kann ich nur
sagen weil das haben wir nicht wollten
dass die ukraine greifen wie nichts wir
haben immer wieder immer wieder erklärt
dass eine situation entsteht wo
unmittelbare sicherheitsbedrohung für
die russische föderation entstehen
ich habe immer wieder viele jahre immer
wieder vorschläge unterbreitet uns wurde
nie gehör geschenkt unter präsident
putin hat das immer wieder verwöhnen
aktien residenz lenski findet gegenüber
putins propaganda presse klare worte
krieg ist unmöglich ohne propaganda
treiber und ich mir sagen dass ihr
genauso verantwortung tragen werdet wie
die die mit raketen schießen wir werden
alles eigentum von den propagandisten
egal wo sie sich befinden beschlagnahmt
sie werden wegen beihilfe zu
kriegsverbrechen strafrechtlich verfolgt
sie werden von den bürgern ihres landes
gehasst die sich ständig betrügen doch
nicht nur russland steht in seiner
kritik auch die eu will selensky in die
pflicht nehmen in diesen tagen wird über
den beitritt der ukraine zur
europäischen union diskutiert wir warten
auf starke unterstützung weil es richtig
menschlich und europäisch ist wir wissen
genau wer hinter uns steht und wer denkt
dass die eu nur ein buchhalter rium ist
wir werden weiter daran arbeiten und
über zeugnis der krieg in der ukraine
geht indes in unvermittelter härte
weiter das leid der menschen wächst von
tag zu tag
unter mir im studio ist der
bild-reporter und russland experte
julian röpke montag julian also es war
ziemlich schrecklich aussagen die wir da
heute gehört haben auf dieser
pressekonferenz in antalya unter anderem
ging es da auch um dieses
kinderkrankenhaus ganz genau also dieses
krankenhaus wurde er gestern bombardiert
in in mario pohl diese schrecklichen
bilder gesehen von dem hochschwangere
menschen die daraus getragen wird und
man überlegt dann heute mal wie könnte
dann eine eine weltmacht russland darauf
reagieren sich entschuldigen dass ein
raum einer untersuchung ankündigen nein
was wir sehen was wir gehört haben von
der labor ist dass wir alles propaganda
es gab sonst keine schwangeren wir haben
quasi etwas gar nicht existiert und dass
das unfassbare ist dass er die menschen
die wir dort sehen die schwangeren die
dort weggetragen wird die werden von
russischen regierung heute als
schauspielerinnen bezeichnet als
schwangere schauspielerinnen die nur für
diesen aktionen dorthin gebracht wurden
darauf hat das erste mal allgemein
angesprochen seine botschaften nämlich
in die russische botschaft in
großbritannien hat das noch
weitergefahren eine der frauen ich hoffe
wir können sie gleich sehen die wir dort
gesehen haben ist marie anna poth kuska
ja jetzt erst mal tatsächlich die
aussage die genaue aussage die laut fda
getroffen hat das ist natürlich
unfassbar was er da sagt nah am sechster
oder siebter märz beim un-sicherheitsrat
hat unsere delegation fakten vorgelegt
das die geburtsklinik schon lange von
ultra radikalen asaf bataillon und
anderen radikalen besetzt wurde
dank und genau und dass man dieses
krankenhaus überhaupt nicht mehr
betreiben könnte also wir haben ja diese
videos gesehen und die videos zeigen
tatsächlich in alle richtungen rund
herum und wir haben viel zerstörte
militärtechnik den letzten tagen gesehen
vor allem von den russen aber auch von
den ukrainern und wir sehen dass es
ausschließlich zivilist was hier ist
also wir sehen dort autos die dort
brennen wir sehen einen großen krater
wir sehen dieses haus und da sehen wir
eben auch diese schwangere die daraus
getragen wird
hochschwanger ist jemand ist sehr
offensichtlich auch wirklich nicht gut
geht ein bisschen mehrere ja das und das
kann ja nicht sein also dass tatsächlich
als schwangere schauspielerin zu
verzeichnen das ist mehr als zynisch
dass das ist es und vor allem ist es
föhnig wenn man sich den einzigen
anhaltspunkt an sich den russland dafür
hat nämlich der anhaltspunkt dass die
eine der schwangeren die wir dort
gesehen haben die bluten die dort
blutüberströmt ausgetragen wurden sie
ist ein model sie ist ein model die hat
einen instagram account und sie hat auch
aus ihrer schwangerschaft aus den
letzten wochen immer wieder ihre fotos
gezeigt wie die großen bauen das ist
jetzt schon der anhaltspunkt hin zu
sagen auch weil sie ein model ist mal
ist er bestimmt auch schauspieler also
dass sich nur anhaltspunkt sondern wir
sehen uns hier das da ist die marie anna
politkowskaja
da wird gesagt nicht ein anhaltspunkt
sondern die frau wurde dorthin geholt um
dort ein opfer zu spielen wir sehen auch
jetzt hier mit ihrem dicken bauch das
ist tatsächlich erst eine woche alt
dieses foto und es war einfach so dass
die frau irgendwann eben ins krankenhaus
musste weil wahrscheinlich die wehen
eingesetzt haben oder biegen nach
voruntersuchungen ich kann es nicht
genau sagen
auf jeden fall das reicht es schon dass
jetzt diese frau erst mal durch
offizielle russische regierung sound ich
habe die britische botschaft die
russische botschaft in großbritannien
genannt angegriffen wird und nicht nur
das ihr instagram
konto wird seitdem mit hassbotschaften
und todes botschaften für die verletzte
schwangere überhäuft und fassbar julian
dankeschön für diese erklärung danke
dass bei uns passt